I'm not I'm not sure what the what the
actual like you know violations were so
the diamond same here again the question
today what do you think about social
media if they need to be regulated as
public utilities Nigel Faraj said that
last time he was on Jordan Peterson said
that this brings us to the topic right
now Jack Dorsey of course has been
appearing all across new media I don't
think we should call it a new meeting
anymore just media media cynically
podcast Joe Rogan Sam Harris to talk
about the company's policies as well as
free speech so the problem here is that
Dorsey continued in my opinion deceives
people about Twitter's real policies
while dodging questions and in criticism
I think a couple things that are
important Jack Dorsey says that he
doesn't want echo that's what he says it
doesn't want echo chambers but it's
important to delineate the difference
between I agree I think all of us would
agree that targeted
harassment targeted libel something that
could result in daxing physical harm
that has no role on social me because
it's a crime in real life by the way but
that's not the same as an echo chamber
and watch him talk about echo chambers
here on that I think this is Joe Rogan
yeah yeah we do incentivize a lot of
echo chambers because we don't make it
easy for people to sound that you saying
and the sack but follows sounds slightly
complex okay so we feel shame if I
followed a bunch of accounts that like
like Boris Johnson who was constantly
giving me information about reasons to
leave come up Rex it yeah I would
probably only see that perspective nigel
Faraj just will not follow accounts that
have a completely different perspective
or a bubble hopefully churn rise to but
most people won't do that well yeah no I
think you're right in here you can kind
of see the solution there where it's
about he was looking at like why is gear
doing this just so I know how short that
is very because you can't see outside
the brim of your hat ah
notice the solution is always to try and
engineer people's like when people don't
follow people with opposing viewpoints
by the way we always encourage you to we
always encourage you to read Huffington
Post and Salon and go watch Fox every
single day we tell you to go read the
green new deal for yourself so if people
make the mistake of not doing that
that's on them but I find it really
interesting that he brings up
and he mentions that as an echo chamber
here's what here's what he's missing all
of the mainstream media BBC and everyone
here in the states all of the news
outlets promoted ain't he brags it
propaganda yeah it's by the way they
were so surprised when Briggs it
happened because they believe their own
lives and because Twitter and new media
was designed to be an alternative
platform what you are seeing are
alternatives alternative points of view
that's what I think people are missing
here Boris Johnson is not more powerful
in the BBC nor is Nigel Faraj but you
get him on Twitter and people are
actually able to hear his ideas they say
well that's a little bit interesting I
didn't know that because before this hat
we do have diversity of ideas here you
you want people to be able to hear the
other side basically what he's saying is
not that I don't want diversity of ideas
he's like I just don't want the ideas I
disagree with he's the source area there
yet but we'll get but that's his point
what's with the hypocrisy of that
statement though he's sitting there
saying people get into a bubble and they
don't look up to it other views
meanwhile hey you want a different view
why don't you go look up Gavin McInnes
on Twitter or Owen Benjamin on Twitter
or Alex Jones on Twitter
so he's censoring people creating a
bubble and then saying there's this
problem where people just get in a
bubble there's real lazy that's a really
good if you're the one your whole thing
is a bubble now dude yeah that's a good
point and here's what's crazy
you know Leptis echo chambers are fine
right wing echo chambers become hate
speech and now we just lose just not
have right wing echo chambers at all
let's just get rid of all of the people
by the way defend Gavin calm so you can
go and help him with his fight DLC new
media everyone was so excited about it
when it started I remember talking about
this in two three years ago when this
was a once a week three-hour show
everyone was saying there's no barrier
entry now I said watch when you see some
conservatives when you see alternative
viewpoints doing well the sharks are
going to come yeah you're going to see
them particularly from old media ABC NBC
CBS Viacom ray Siena Trey Turner you're
going to see them go after YouTube where
they cannot win on a level playing field
as it relates to viewers as it relates
to content so how do they win money and
censoring the opposition and here we are
now this was the whole purpose to new
media what so that someone like a Boris
Johnson or Nigel Faraj could have just
as loud of a voice as the BBC yeah Kevin
we should make it clear to there there
is such a thing as Nazis there is a tiny
group of Pepe Nut Bars who Photoshop you
and I with swastikas and gas chambers
and they talk about the JQ
and the 14 words in the 88 and all their
little jargon stuff and if you allow
those guys into your platform it tends
to be pretty bad for your platform they
tend to just make everyone go I'm
getting out of here right there's sort
of like the gremlins were talking about
the other day but on the other side but
that's it's letting a bunch of guys crap
in the parking lot where everyone's
tailgating exactly no one else wants to
be there right but those those tailgate
crappers are a very tiny sliver and
they're very easy to identify right and
I think Twitter started out doing a
pretty good job of getting rid of that
tiny minority of lunatic Nazis maybe
like 1% of the population or much less
than half a percent and then they they
were normal for a while and comedians
could tell horrible jokes and iron out
content and it's pretty fun and then
using the justification of the sliver
the tailgate crappers they started just
getting anyone Christian conservative
remotely controversial and now it's kind
of the opposite by the way the only
people I know that use the term nutbar
are you and kevin O'Leary you know
you're sounding like some kind of a left
wing nut bar I'm out oh in his interview
with Dorsey actually Sam Harris who I
would actually I would love to have Sam
Harris in the show but I do find
listening to his show sometimes painful
it can be very dull but it doesn't mean
there's a show I just have to watch it
sometimes it's out of necessity
Sam Harris pointed out that a liberal
feminist by the way was banned for
saying that men aren't women here you go
Megan Murphy feminist but she's not
sufficiently woke apparently on the
transgender topic and she she wrote a
tweet which I believe red men are not
women and got suspended over that tweet
you suspend it right away and not to
tell my own substrate when there was a
clear concerted campaign led by as you
mentioned white supremacist websites and
of course their acquiescent liberals on
social media to defame and paint me as a
neo-nazi with fake tweets like gasps the
Jews hanging the n-words Twitter by the
way took no action you have those Falls
done libelous tweets removed that's
important that's they said it to repeat
it this is what it's like the timeline
with the FAQ from Cortes yeah said well
it has the wrong one you answered
questions all day I made a mistake
all day long okay what do you want
googly googly she could fit right in and
like a trash can come out like I'm
trying to sleep in here too cute man you
bring up the overlay here the memes some
of them and remain up today by the way
yeah repeated then targeted libelous
tweets try to destroy the ability for
anyone here to make a living
didn't violate Twitter's policies and by
the way also tried to Doc's me just
didn't work and they're still up today
they live in the Silicon Valley echo
chamber that's their echo chamber
they're like well I don't want this
points like I don't wanna Briggs it we
echo chamber corridors what do you think
mark and Susan yes yeah it's like
consensus yes and that when they call
his white nationalist white nationalist
get pissed on this race thing that he's
always cooking for shekels race-mixing
jus love her who hangs out with gays I
don't like that guy and it's sort of
like 9/11 - or they goes 9/11 was an
inside job in the Turks Co we busted our
ass on that attack right take her down
the Twin Towers Martin Sheen is sitting
there like I'm pretty sure was that I
was jus Dick Cheney Dick Cheney what's
with some bird shots
it's especially friend that Jack in that
interview Jack Dorsey he mentions
journalists you specifies the importance
of journalists since Twitter goes out of
its way to ensure that the
hypersensitive leftist journalists don't
receive any criticism at all know people
who jokingly tweeted learn to code at
the journalists were suspended
immediately record time they learn to
code that journalist many people for
acerbic wit now versus saying that the
main thing if computers existed back in
the time of Jack Benny he'd be like
learn to code it's also good advice you
know they'd have better job security if
they knew how to code please we would
love to have you on this program of
course we would be fair is it about
preventing right-wing ideas and or
science from spreading theirs at about
echo chambers let us know I think
another point that people really need to
at least it needs to be illuminated is
the reasons for the bans yeah because
dorsey's been going around and I want to
know also by the way another question
how do you think the interviewers have
treated him I've heard a lot of people
complain saying that they thought he
wasn't pressed enough by some of these
podcasts and then some people say that
they think it's productivity than any
podcast at all
even though I think it's reductive if
he's in a podcast but not if he
repeatedly lies and then switches yeah I
said just kidding I had my fingers
crossed which we'll get to in a little
bit parently went back to Jack Benny
nobody's calling him on it I mean it's
kind of hard to call out the guy who is
the gatekeeper essentially right but
it's hard to call out people unless
you're sixty minutes you're so happy to
get a huge guest like that I gotta be
honest if I Jack Dorsey I would spend
the interview kissing his ass really yes
probably physically you've seen this
video of Gavin kissing someone's ass
like a million place but you a Photoshop
pen please
we're so many obese these days and we're
so bad at conflict that when you get a
good guest and you hammer them you have
a back and forth you'll never get a
liberal again you'll never get a famous
person again right so you have to sort
of it's like feeding a squirrel you have
to be like thanks for coming on the show
Jack okay you do your propaganda and
then I'll maybe cast aspersions after
you leave important point that kind of
segues into the fact that Dorsey
repeatedly said that Twitter should have
been more clear about why people were
banned what the terms of service best
but here he is explaining it but realize
that we're probably gonna make some
mistakes along the way and all we can do
that beard corrects and let's just be
open about where we are that's probably
where we failed you lost in the past is
we just haven't been open about what led
to particular decisions how our Terms of
Service this is the go-to whenever
someone gets banned it's well if you
read the Terms of Service you know why
you were banned but then if you ask them
how a specific person violated the terms
of service they refuse to give an answer
watch Torcy do it right here I'm not I'm
not sure what the what the actual like
you know violations were but we have we
have a set number of actions Megan
Murphy when I was banned it's that we
you leave read the man or not women the
case you brought up I'm not sure what's
behind the Megan Murphy men
women tween their CEO I could talk to or
something you know when I was banned it
said you've been permanently suspended
for semicolon space what do you mean the
abyss what does that mean to reason
either hoots you it doesn't matter what
the term is by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
on YouTube because apparently
subscriptions don't mean anything join
mud clips I get to the Daily Show
a lot of credit a comm slash mug Club
subscribe on iTunes for the audio
version of course rate it and by the way
big for our Oscars live for February
24th torture at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
breaking game rules they posted no the
whole point is we watch it so you guys
don't have to and I think Gavin might be
at least making an appearance
oh yeah oh Jesus I'm gonna be at the
Oscars I was invited I'm gonna be in the
front row with sitting with a woman
named Penelope Millions
really yeah is an actual thing yeah she
rescued Harvey Weinstein's daughter from
a fire and I'm gonna be there for the
Oscar for worst liar okay the only thing
that jack has been consistent about is
stressing that harassment campaigns are
the most ban of Allah fence and I think
we all agree with that here yeah but
we've already seen that those campaigns
don't apply to targeted repeated libel
of someone like myself or Gavin by the
way or a more recent example they're
coming to new school kids yeah
celebrities were calling for the kids
addresses yeah wanting them to be harmed
because a kid smiled at a toothless meth
head who was twice deferred sorry twice
when a wall as a veteran was a
refrigerator repairman and was wearing a
Mogga hat yeah they called for school
shootings they said it would be a great
school to shoot up and you know what the
Wright doesn't do that like how many
times have dat'll Ash had to move we
can't show pictures of our kids you look
at Chris Hayes and Mark Ruffalo they're
all like here's our kids right yeah I
don't even say my kids names right
because so their kids I mean look
[ __ ] let's be honest they all look
so jacked offices by the way that he
hasn't focused we're gonna get
breathless if it's a grounded guy who
would call you up for that he will
what's happening said you and I don't
even know what your kids look like but
if they look like you they haven't
focused enough from what he said Dorsey
on the off-site ramifications at Twitter
here's a clip
focused on enough we haven't focused on
the f-off platform ramifications of what
happens online so basically I didn't
even need that clip because I told you
you're right check Dorsey you haven't
because you've been more worried about
journalists receiving slightly mean
tweets or people making scientifically
accurate claims it might offend I don't
know point five percent of the
population by the way you miss Isis
recruiting bomb threats and tufa staging
violent assaults on people because you
were more worried about a BuzzFeed
boldly getting her feelings out of our
doctor pointing out her BMI of 76 okay
this is what's been happening good folks
in the offset ramifications do you mean
like daxing kids from a school with a
maggot that's and murky territory I'm
gonna seek my wise counsel Zuckerberg
somebody and Cortes probably has private
meetings but I think another point
obviously is a that people need to to
see hear certain segments of these
interviews Jack actually kind of lets
the mask slip and the good thing is we
get to see kind of like what the
abortion laws we now get to see the true
agenda of Twitter where I want Twitter
specifically to go is I you know I I
think it's existential right now that we
we we have global conversations about
some things that will become crisis
climate change being one of them there's
no one that's going to solve that
problem alone economic disparities in
the rise of AI and job displacement and
and just like us all flirting decisions
to really puts the world at a
disadvantage because it incentivizes
more of the echo chambers which lead to
things like nationalism instead of
taking the broader picture no simply you
could write a clickbait headlines
radical globalist Jack Dorsey now
pushing anti human green New Deal agenda
and it would be accurate yeah wouldn't
be clickbait that's what do you say
actually I think what's important is
this in this final clip up some here Sam
here's got Jack Dorsey to admit that
they're they're no longer trying to be
neutral here you singing I I don't
believe that we can afford to take a
neutral
stance I don't blindly honestly we
should optimize for neutrality
vissa do believe that we should optimize
for impartiality and I do think there's
a what to me a neutral neutrality is a
lot more passive a lot more hands-off I
don't think we can just be be this
neutral passive platform is we don't
want to hang neutral but we want to be
unfair
he's hoping everybody will be asleep we
want to ensure that fairness plays no
role on our platform I'm sure he knows
what he's talking about how did you do
an interview with Joe Rogan for four
hours and so I don't know what that's
what the violation was and it's really
important that we have freedom of speech
and then you go on hear you say yeah I
don't remember the I don't know the time
on which shows he did but you would go
on shows for hours and say yeah yeah we
want it to be an open platform for all
and then it's like now we don't we like
over Sonia Sotomayor Supreme Court judge
- yeah I should be a Supreme Court judge
I'm I'm totally impartial I'm gonna be a
great judge then she gets in she goes I
will we will be lying if we didn't say
that our background and our Hispanic
heritage didn't affect our decisions
your job as a judge it should not be a
Hispanic woman right just an impartial
you know judge justice is blind and then
you have Jack Dorsey going we are
totally neutral here we're just gonna be
impartial let everyone make their own
decisions and we obviously can't be
neutral about that when we do that it'll
be with the left-wing Ben and they won
by the way just because people getting a
message out their truth yes that one's
brexit this idea that it was a lot a
good example you know what a lie is that
some kid harassed a Native American
toothless meth head who is twice
deferred sorry I went AWOL or frigerator
fair man Vietnam because in a marga hat
that is a lie not that they're obsessed
to being an autonomous nation this is
this is a great example of what we've
been talking about all week the Left
fears transparency they run from it they
check under their bed for it so it's a
good indicator if someone tries to shut
down transparency that their leftist or
a liar but I repeat myself and that's
what we're seeing with Jeff it's not
just a Cascio cortes with this this this
is this is in your deal no us no it's
not but you wrote it I
updated the wrong copy questions I know
nothing this is Jack this is what Jack
is doing well hold on a second what are
you what's going on well really we
should be more clear about our policies
well what are your policies I don't
really want to talk about that right
well what do you think the Polish eats
it's in Iran well should Center on being
neutral okay so how are you gonna be
neutral we don't want to be neutral do I
need to shoot myself because I don't get
my spots are into trouble if you want to
know what Silicon Valley is just picture
Bernie Cory Booker Acacio car Ted
sitting in a boardroom deciding what can
and cannot be said on the Internet
that's what Silicon Valley is the
politicians the far-left politicians I
should say are just like the Silicon
Valley tech executives they use nice
words like transparency truth safety but
whenever you ask some questions they run
for cover you so the same thing when
Zuckerberg yeah when he had to testify
when you saw the same thing with widgets
key remember back then she's like wow I
think it's important that we have a
neutral well how you gonna do that well
but we don't want hate speech what's
hate speech when you start shining a
light on these guys they scurry back
into the darkness that's why there's no
accountability when we explain where we
line up here on every issue yeah well
we're really quick ok Jack we're not
trying to attack you we just want to put
all the cards in the table that's all
we're asking for you let's not even go
to the public utilities debate but we
just we've all agree we all agreed we
talked about this yesterday we you have
to be honest about your business
practices you can't say we weren't clear
about the Terms of Service and then we
said well what are the terms of service
and you know I don't know I don't even
know honey that's not what it can be we
just want to know where everyone stands
on these platforms but instead they flip
over the table and they throw the cards
away that's what Silicon Valley is
Acacio Cortez come out now I'm doing it
affected
Acacio Cortez no not you o kzo Cortez II
I just want to say Camila hairs / Cory
Booker in a boardroom that's what it is
and now that you know you just have to
play by their rules or get kicked off
the platform hey social media let
freedom ring hey there if you like this
video subscribe to the channel or hit
the notification bell do it I'll wait a
second do you hear that little ding it
actually did make a ding sound I just
did it would happen while my mouth was
doing it and you thought it was coming
from your computer so that's fun also
there's some videos playing in these
boxes next to me go watch those you
might enjoy them you might not
don't care